MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Cost optimization
is about more than saving money.
It's about maximizing the
return on what you're spending.
Let's walk through how to
optimize your costs for Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
Today, we'll be talking
about some general tips
for getting started with cost
optimization and some best
practices.
In other words, let's
go beyond your GKE bill.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Individuals and companies
alike are talking about,
experimenting with, and
deploying apps on Kubernetes.
And of course, GKE
is made to scale
as you add more traffic
and more applications.
However, scaling your apps might
also mean scaling your costs.
And as more teams in your
organization use Kubernetes,
it may become more
complex to manage.
Let's look at some
ways to think about how
you can optimize your usage,
and your costs, for GKE.
I'll get started by quickly
going over some basics,
and then talk about the
business and culture side.
Then, I'll go over some
general technical tips.
Simply put, what you're
paying for with GKE
itself is primarily two things--
the managed architecture for
actually running the Kubernetes
cluster, and the resources
that your apps are running on,
such as CPUs,
memory, and storage.
There's also a few
other things that
will affect your costs,
like networking and resource
location.
We'll dive into details to
better understand and optimize
different areas in these videos.
But no matter what
the costs are,
it's hard to make
decisions without knowing
where they're coming from.
Being able to have visibility
into all the different moving
pieces is incredibly important.
And a great place
to start might be
using a dashboard to help
visualize your resources.
The next videos will
go over some tips
for exactly how to do that.
But try to always remember
that the more you understand
about the full details
of your applications,
the more opportunities
you'll have to optimize.
And don't worry.
You'll hear me say
that plenty of times.
On top of that, you
shouldn't forget
about the people
that are actually
writing the applications.
When you're in a rush to deploy
an application, sometimes,
shortcuts get taken.
Or maybe your organization
has grown so large
that they completely abstract
Kubernetes away from the teams,
and then they're not even sure
how their apps make it to GKE.
Either way, keeping developers,
operators, and everyone else
in the dark about how their
applications actually run
might cause more harm than good.
Instead, consider
spending the time
to train your technical
teams on Kubernetes
best practices, like
online classes, code labs,
even videos like this one.
When teams understand
and care about the cost
it takes to run their
apps, the more those teams
will be able to optimize.
Beyond that, you can
also implement guardrails
to protect yourself from
updates that might significantly
affect your costs.
There are ways to automatically
enforce policies and set up
quotas for resources
that we'll also
cover in this video series.
Building a culture of
awareness and accountability
is critical to being able
to optimize your costs.
Keeping all of that in
mind, let's switch over
to some best practices
on the technical side.
You can find reference
links in the description
if you want to read
more about any of these.
So if you're already
using GKE, you're
probably aware of your
production clusters.
But how many development
clusters do you have?
Smaller teams might work well
with one cluster per developer.
But you should actually look
at multi-tenant clusters
to save on overhead.
By using namespaces and policies
to keep resources capped
and isolated, dev teams can
have the room to experiment
that won't lead to
any surprise bills.
On top of that,
there's a few add-ons
that come with GKE clusters that
are important for production
environments, but might not
be needed for your development
environments.
For each of your
smaller clusters,
consider disabling
or limiting add-ons
if you're not using them,
such as Cloud Logging
and Monitoring, Horizontal Pod
Autoscaling, the Kubernetes
Dashboard, and Kube DNS.
Most can be disabled
with a one-line command.
These small add-ons can add up.
So the better you understand
what your apps need
and the environment around
them, the more you can optimize.
Speaking of what your
apps need, do you
know what your pod
disruption budgets are?
You can set the number of pods
or the percentage of pods that
can be taken down when
doing voluntary disruptions,
like upgrades or autoscaling.
Think about the
minimum amount of pots
that you need to run without
disrupting your applications'
users.
And think about that for each
application independently.
Pod disruption budgets
can help keep your apps
running as you
configure autoscaling
without overprovisioning.
We'll talk more about
autoscaling soon.
If you're not sure
about how to figure out
things like resource utilization
or pod disruption budgets,
stay tuned.
On the next video,
we'll talk all
about monitoring
your GKE environment
and getting better
observability.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]